[Musik]
wie jedes jahr bot sich new york raus
zur weihnachtszeit aber dieses jahr ist
alles anders
die berühmten einkaufsstraße die fifth
avenue sich sonst jeden tag
hunderttausende menschen aus aller welt
durch den weihnachtstrubel zwängen für
new yorker verhältnisse wie ausgestorben
die geschäfte haben dichtgemacht und
denen die noch offen sind wird die
kundschaft die pandemie hat die stadt an
den wirtschaftlichen abgrund geführt
[Musik]
26 millionen menschen hungern in amerika
sind auf lebensmittelhilfen angewiesen
mit zwei millionen alleine in new york
rechnet der bürgermeister
anna ist eine von ihnen 16 jahre hat sie
als putzfrau gearbeitet mit ihren
arbeitgebern angst einjagte seit beginn
der pandemie habe ich keinen job mehr
ich habe noch ein bisschen erspartes
aber das reicht nicht und noch lange
durchzuhalten
ich schlafe nur noch schlecht habe angst
ich frage mich wie lange ich diese
situation noch überleben kann
aber der hunger sei noch nicht einmal
ihr größtes problem
das wichtigste für mich ist die miete zu
bezahlen ist wenn man zu hause
ich kann zwei drei tage nichts essen
aber ich kann nicht auf der straße leben
schon gar nicht als frau in new york
einer der reichsten städte der welt
rechnet man damit dass nach weihnachten
mehr als 100.000 menschen ihre wohnung
verlieren könnten für doris salmon aber
war es das geschäftsjahr ihres lebens
doris ist bestattungsunternehmer in das
ganze jahr über haben wir sie immer
wieder getroffen
seit 40 jahren sind sie und ihren
leichenwagen im geschäft noch nie hätte
sie so viel zu tun gehabt wie in den
vergangenen monaten erzählt sie uns
jetzt kurz vor weihnachten treffen wir
sie zu hause in ihrem appartement mit
atemberaubenden blick auf den atlantik
gleich neben coney island den berühmten
new yorker vergnügungspark niemals
niemals im leben hätte ich mir
vorstellen können dass wir in unserem
zeitalter eine solche pandemie erleben
das war was aus der vergangenheit die
pest gelbfieber typhus aber heute mit
unserer technologie
das hat mich geschockt sehr geschockt
zehn manchmal 15 beerdigungen habe sie
über monate pro tag managen müssen
finanziell habe sie von der pandemie
profitiert vor der tür im maserati
cabrio aber in ihrer nachbarschaft wie
überall in der stadt da sähe es düster
aus
viele geschäfte sind pleite ich habe
glück dass meine branche systemrelevant
ist aber die kleinen die hat es erwischt
schumacher friseure jims alle pleite
die liste ist endlos ich fühle mit
diesen menschen wie wollen sie sich
jemals davon erholen
1200 dollar unterstützung von der
regierung ernsthaft das reicht bei den
meisten doch noch nicht mal für ein
halbe monat miete nicht alle sind pleite
aber viele pfeifen auf dem letzten loch
und der harte corona winter vor dem die
behörden warnen hat gerade erst begonnen
wir sind in chinatown alle hier tragen
masken auch draußen auf der straße
die asiatische community hat die
niedrigste infektionsrate in der ganzen
stadt
aber der wirtschaftliche abschwung
trifft auch sie mit voller wucht das
restaurant hockey ist eine institution
in manhattan seit 1939 ist das
restaurant familienbesitz prominente wie
star koch anthony bourdain kamen
regelmäßig doch seit monaten sei sein
geschäft praktisch tot erzählt uns peter
lee der eigentümer wir halten uns an die
regeln ich habe luftfilter eingebaut und
die tische auseinander gezogen schau dir
an was ich gemacht habe
normalerweise habe ich all diese tisch
aber jetzt muss ich auf die abstände
achten
am wochenende hatte ich immer volles
haus freitag samstag sonntag wie viele
gäste 168 personen 168 ja auf einmal und
jetzt habe ich noch nicht mal ein volles
haus bei den 42 gästen die mir erlaubt
sind und jetzt hat auch noch der
gouverneur essen im lokal wieder ganz
verboten weil die infektionszahlen
steigen yan li ist peters vermieter
viele geschäfte hätten schon aufgegeben
und würden auch nicht mehr zurückkommen
erzählte uns seinen mietern aber habe er
die miete vorübergehend reduziert und
gst
und er ist wütend auf die die dafür
verantwortlich sind dass es in der stadt
immer wieder vermehrt zu ausbrüchen der
krankheit kommt das korrespondiert mit
den orten an denen die leute keine
massen tram und die infizieren dann
wieder uns alle
sie fahren mit der u-bahn mit dem bus
laufen durch die stadt
das bringt die rate hoch und davon ist
nicht unser fehler ist müssen wir unsere
geschäfte wieder schließen das ist sehr
unfair uns gegenüber die pandemie war
macht auch denen zu schaffen die sich
sonst um ein gutes geschäft in new york
nie sorgen mussten luxusimmobilien in
der weltmetropole galten jahrzehnte als
sichere geldanlage
aber auch dieser markt sei seit beginn
der krise zusammengebrochen erklärt uns
sebastian steinau preisabschläge in den
wolkenkratzern enorm letzte woche wurde
eine unit ort verkauft eine wohnung mit
400 quadratmetern spektakulärer unit
aber mit eben großen abschlägen die
wurde 2014 für 34 millionen gekauft und
jetzt letzte woche für 22 millionen
verkauft das heißt 35% rabatt 12
millionen abschlag für eine wohnung für
anna klingt das nach einem märchen aus
einem anderen universum wo sie wohnt
sollen wir nicht zeigen denn anna ist
illegal in den usa per handy video zeigt
sie uns ihr zimmer neun quadratmeter
bett fernseher kühlschrank keine fenster
550 dollar im monat
mit jedem tag den die pandemie länger
andauert wachs ihre angst erzählte uns
lange können sie nicht mehr durchhalten
es wird wie es aussieht ein sehr
bitterer winter für viele menschen hier
in new york
[Musik]